how many followers do you have on
Instagram maybe
150 all time though right there folks so
what do you do on Instagram that makes
people not want to follow you name three
slang words from Our Generation
Um can I just just do a Tik Tok dance do
a Tik Tok dance said do a Tik Tok dance
do you guys know that goated
dance no do you have R like get what's
your best pickup line the thing is my RZ
is on on such a level that I don't need
to pull cuz they're already pulling me
you know like I just got to walk so you
have no RZ my RZ needs no words is what
I'm trying to say like like I come in
and you know why should we think you're
cool I know how to bring the
energy in your squad if you need to I
like your shoes thank you so much thank
you where do you work I am a data
scientist I work on like what kind of
data data like I do machine learning so
I work on things you like chat PT and
those kind of things like
I that's
like I'm
sorry it's just it's just like yeah sure
it's like you seem like a fun person
some of the things didn't really seem so
cool about you the fact that you only
have 150 but I will say I have twice as
many followers as I have following I
still stand by my decision though